Like, let's say...
Yeah.
Let's say that the, you know,
you're running,
let's say you have like chemotherapy,
right?
It could be the chemotherapy was noted on
January 1st, 2017,
but the note itself says patient started
chemotherapy, like Srinil said,
on January 1st, 2015.
I do think both of those dates are
important.
I don't think that both of those dates
should go to the client because.
a lot of times it creates a tonne of
confusion for the client. So downstream,
Yeah.
I don't necessarily want to do that,
but I do think that it's important for us,
especially when we're reconciling and
tracing back, right?
Or if we're looking at using that URL to
kind of trace back patients,
Yeah.
it is important for us to know what date
is on there and if there is a,
so like it sounds like these are all
dates that are on the note itself, right?
But.
Big.
If another date is like,
let's say row 1054, open splenectomy,
let's say that actually was an open
splenectomy that the doctor wrote about
on January 5th, 2025, but it's history of.
And sometimes it won't say that when that
Yeah.
was. And in that case,
the best date we have is January 5th,
2025.
Although there really should be something
in there that says its history of,
because we want to differentiate that
from like a current active splenectomy.
Right.
The other thing is,
if there is a date mentioned on there,
or even a month, year,
like I would be really interested in
seeing what that was, because, and again,
that has,
that's a different concept than the date
on the note.
Yeah, okay,
so I see some examples in here that are
Yes, sir.
called,
that are status history that seem to
Oh, interesting. Exactly.
There's a star next to that date.
Yeah.
represent. Yeah, yeah.
What does that mean?
I'm going to assume from Jeff that that
means that that's,
we're calling out that that's the Fed
date that then was mentioned in the note,
not necessarily the date and all
likelihood,
That.
not the date that was performed.
But we should have another field in here,
Okay.
I agree,
if we don't have it that says historical
Mm.
date or something like that.
or historical, some way of capturing.
Yeah.
Something, yeah, something to capture.
And I'm sure sometimes that will be
specified and sometimes that it won't,
right,
because the patient won't remember when
There's plenty of time that's, oh yeah,
there's plenty of time that's not.
it was or, yeah, yeah.
Yeah,
most of the time I think we just use the
note date,
but it is good if we do have it because
then when we're talking to the client,
a lot of the note dates don't make sense
to them, right? They're like, well,
you're telling me that the, like,
Right.
especially when it comes to like tumours
and metastasis, right? It's like,
you're telling me that it metastasized to
the liver.
but then we're looking at it and we're
seeing that it's already in the lung,
but how did,
like what time frame did that happen?
And we're not being able to kind of give
them that story that they're looking for.
Yeah.
Yeah, that makes perfect sense.
Yeah,
and I think from a traceability
standpoint that will help.
I don't even know. I don't know if...
Yeah.
Like,
I'm fine with how it is in our current
NLP output, where one column is the, like,
you know,
we have one field or column for the date
of the note and one column for.
encounter event date if it happens to be
a different day. That's noted in the note.
Yeah.
So I'm fine with that,
but it sounds like Jeremy you had
thoughts that this should be a separate
table.
Or did you, I think,
I think a little like a little bit ago
Sorry, say that again.
You lost me at one point there.
when shrinal brought up this concept,
you would said maybe that the history
should be in a separate table than this,
but are you are you still thinking that,
Oh, okay, yes. Well,
I was thinking of the way,
or do you think?
so what under the comment that Andres
made about,
so we build these tables in the summaries,
but inevitably there are,
let's call them stragglers.
There are there are there are facts or
Yeah.
information in the patient history that
don't neatly fit into one of these
categories, and one of them might be...
Patient broke their leg when they were
seven years old, or something like,
you know, some sort of bit of information.
So I think there needs to be a home.
Ideally, in the structured data,
there should be a home for these bits of
information that don't logically fit into
diagnosis, treatment, procedures, la bala.
However,
I agree with what you two have expressed
about where we can if historical events
are mentioned in the notes.
that are not,
the event is not actually recorded
anywhere in the notes. You know,
patient had a, you know,
some surgery 20 years ago.
There should be some way.
I guess that's the question is,
do we list that in the procedure table or
do we list that in some sort of
inferred historical data type of table.
So although it comes down to the
confidence that we have and that
information.
Yeah.
I think too, I mean,
because we have been discussing that for
our use cases.
So sometimes it's contractory,
the requirements, right? Like,
you could say, for example, like,
a note today in October, like, oh,
I had a, I don't know,
The second.
like a bladder surgery May last year.
And it's like, okay,
which note do you put? In some use cases,
they want to have, like,
even if you mentioned that was in May,
the notice from today put.
Today, but...
Semantically doesn't make sense.
Semantically,
or the meaning itself is in May.
So I think the best thing to do is for
every event at least two dates. One date,
that is the date this is being extracted
with links to the existing node,
and I don't know, like it's a tautology,
but the chronological node,
when this event took place.
So one date allows you to ascribe the
source note and the other date it's used
Oh.
Yeah.
for like logical analysis.
And it's not expanding the table,
it's just having two dates.
And when you only have one,
you just put the node date, right?
Because that's the anchor that you have.
You don't have anything else.
So I think that solves the two things and
doesn't make you choose one or the other.
That's how we're thinking to address this.
Yeah.
Except that there's historical stuff,
there will be times when the historical
stuff,
the time information that you want to be
captured cannot be captured by a single
date.
And.
I'm sure there will be.
So we need something a little more
flexible there.
Yeah.
And then I...
For example,
patient was type 2 diabetic between 1990
and 1988 or something like that.
Oh,
that gets captured outside of the table
in the bullet points that we keep.
Right, the things that need a home. Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
All right, I mean,
I think we can work through,
I think maybe...
So I'm getting a lot out of this
conversation.
I know we're short on time and you all
are very busy.
I think maybe a good way to work through,
so I think we've identified what are the
core sort of gaps between what we produce
and what you see as, you know,
Mhm.
a real source of value.
I think we could work through a lot of
that in writing.
Like we can go back and forth,
Okay.
asynchronously, give an example,
define it and so forth.
I think the thing that's like the
critical question,
which I don't think we're going to answer
2 minutes here, of course,
Yeah.
probably without ilan on the call either,
is like, what are the steps?
in this process. So,
and I can throw out what I think it looks
like to me,
and we can come back to talk about it. So,
so we need to work through this feedback.
We need to get to a common understanding
of these details about what we know,
what to whatever something like 9095%
there.
I think the next the next two steps I
Okay.
Yeah.
I see as one,
we need to do an evaluation similar to
the evaluation that we're talking about
for the structured,
other structured data feeds,
where we have some experts go through
these,
evaluate precision and recall correctness,
Because.
and come up with some baseline numbers,
just baselines, I think,
Mhm.
just kind of set the stage.
And then the second thing is.
The.
Can we do some customer discovery around
that,
or do we already have some customer
discovery around this? Because, you know,
our very sort of dumb way of thinking
about that question is like, look,
if we make this, will people buy it?
Yeah.
And obviously there's nuance to that, but.
..
No, I was going to say, yeah, I agree.
And I think, as you said,
with some of these things, I mean,
there's two additional things that come
Sure.
to mind too.
So I can just type them and send them
over if that's helpful.
And this way we can start working at it
Please do.
because I think you guys do have like 90%
there.
It's just a few things that we've seen
along the way.
Sorry.
that might be helpful for you to add in
there.
Yeah.
And then what you're talking about for
like the next steps and that, yeah,
maybe on Wednesday when Elan's there as
well,
we can get on the call and kind of see
what are the next steps from here.
Yeah.
Just to recap quicker for you, Allison,
I was, you know,
Yes.
let's close the gap between what we've
got and all of your great suggestions.
I think we can do that asynchronously,
mostly in writing.
Okay.
Let's do a simple evaluation of this,
like we talked about with the framework
for the other feeds,
get some baseline metrics,
and then the other next step would be...
You know,
us understand customer discovery,
us understanding like, you know,
how saleable is this?
What is it going to take? You know,
should we keep pushing?
Thanks.
I.
Yeah, I mean, I think I think it's great.
I think I really agree with your point
that like,
let's just get everything out of the
notes.
We can figure out downstream from there
how, how we want,
like what we want in terms of how we want
to like.
use it downstream and filter,
but I think this is,
I personally think this is great.
I think the concept that you get a 360
view into everything for that patient is
a huge differentiator between what we
Okay.
have now.
Um...
OK.
So I'm happy to do another round of
feedback once you have something that you
want me to...
Yeah,
I'll work through the feedback you've
Forgot to.
already provided. I'll create, you know,
make sure that it's clear so that folks
Perfect.
like Jeff and Andres can make changes.
Once we get through that,
we'll produce another round of output.
And if, and if it's, you know,
if it looks good to you too,
then we'll do,
we'll plan an evaluation and get some
metrics.
Perfect. That sounds great. Yeah,
I would love that.
And then if we need to have another
meeting for this topic, we can.
Okay.
I know there's a few different work
streams.
Yep, yes, so, so Alison, you know,
after this, right,
Yeah, but let's.
so the jeremy second point about customer
validation,
I think we should not immediately,
but maybe after one round,
let's start thinking about that, right?
I think ideally I would want to find one
Yeah.
or two beta customers that we can partner
with, right,
Yeah.
and basically bring in some of their
actual use cases.
and then use this feed to solve their
problems.
Yeah.
And this, the thing is that,
so how are you, I know you have,
I know we're at the end of time,
but how would you,
Yeah.
how are you envisioning this working?
Like you're giving a three,
you're pulling a 360 view of everything
for patients.
When clients are working with us now,
the model under which we sell and licence
data is very specific concepts or
entities that come out of it. For example,
it would, instead of being diagnoses,
it would be a diagnosis for.
IGAN, right? But here you're gonna pull,
let's say you have a top of the funnel.
Are you thinking that you'd pull like for
that specific top of the funnel cohort,
all of this data out for them?
Is that like one model we could work with?
Yes.
Yes, I mean that would be, yeah, yeah,
so that would be, you know.
That's a, that's just interesting. I mean,
this would be so different than what we
do now.
Yep, but look,
it's going to be the most scalable
product in terms of sales in this area,
right? If, yes,
because then we can just go and sell
literally and we process the whole thing
Totally, totally.
once and we can sell as many as we want
with no custom work needed, right?
This can bring in substantial revenue
opportunities.
Totally.
What if we wanted to do something
depending on like the pricing where we
did not push everything through?
Would that be really difficult to filter?
It.
Yeah, yeah, so that...
Look, so there are,
there are two types of philtre philtres
possible, right? We can, so,
so one is of course cohort, right? So,
even though we will have everything
processed, we'll, you know, we'll sell,
you know, disease by disease,
condition by condition, et cetera,
Mhm.
Yeah.
and then we, in terms of pricing,
we can have different types of packages
per se, right?
We can have some which are very
restrictive to certain number of fields,
certain type of information that is.
you know, gold, plant, platinum, silver,
you know, whatever,
however you guys want to define it, right?
So there could be one which is more
expensive, that includes everything,
and there is some very cheap one with
extremely limited information and
something in between.
Yeah.
Okay,
and then you have to think about how we'd
price those differently. But yeah,
the first step is just seeing if they
yip.
work, because I agree,
those are two very different concepts.
Yeah.
Super interesting.
Yep, and, and look,
the other use of course, yeah,
I want to pilot one of each. Yes, sorry,
go ahead.
the other use of it is essentially
helping accelerate, you know,
I.
Yes.
these custom projects as well, right?
But that's a separate use because now,
instead of even summary,
this output can become the input for a
Yeah.
lot of that work, right?
This output plus the structured output
that we already have,
structured data that we already have,
we just write code.
You know, you know,
post-process this stuff and make it more
specialized, right,
for a given customer project. So,
Just.
so that's a given pretty much,
and I would want to find at least one or
two use cases from the existing backlog
where we use that, you know,
output as input and essentially deliver
them and measure ourselves in terms of
Mhm.
quality and time and everything else,
right? So, we should do that too.
I think that's there is value right there,
but I, but I'm equally interested,
if not more, in coming up with a general,
you know, sellable feed with, you know,
tiered pricing model and so on and so
forth,
because that's that's what it scales,
right? That requires nothing,
no custom work.
And it also allows you, I mean,
the main vision at the beginning was like,
yeah,
working with notes is hard because
they're massive, right?
But this summaries give you, let's say,
10 to 20 times compression.
So it's way smaller.
And then perhaps someone wants like a
very specific line of therapy analysis
with an index diagnose.
then you reprocess,
but you don't reprocess the notes,
you reprocess the summaries,
which is way faster.
Yes, yeah.
And cheaper, right?
Thank you.
And you can deliver a project too, yeah.
And the LLM is smart enough that even
Yeah.
though it's not in the summary explicitly
a fishery one,
with that context builds the analysis
downstream. And yeah, makes it cheaper,
Mhm.
You.
faster, and scales quite nicely. Because
If a client pays for one and you're
summarising those patients,
those summaries are billed for the next
plan that asks for another thing.
Yeah, yeah, not just summaries, right?
We this entire feed is going to be
available for everyone, right?
In all kind of use cases, that's it,
that's where a lot of, you know,
scaling benefits come from, but great,
yeah, thank you, glad to see it, you know,
the...
Great, yeah, that would be great.
I do want to try out,
Yeah.
like when we're at the point of like
testing these with clients,
I would love to try out one version
that's the filtering of the cohort,
but like a 360 view of everything and
then another that's a specific cohort,
The.
but also filtering to specific concepts
or encounters within it, right? Yeah,
Sure.
so it would be cool to see both of those
and also the level of effort it takes
downstream for post-processing for.
my team, your team, whoever,
to do that and support that one.
Cool. All right. Thank you so much.
Really appreciate your time and looking
All right.
Thank you.
Thanks.
forward to seeing the next iteration.
All right,
I'll work through the feedback and write
Yeah.
I've seen.
it up and share. Okay.
Alright, thank you.
Thank you so much. Bye.
Thanks. Bye.